Deși calculatoarele cuantice nu vor fi potrivite pentru a rezolva
toate problemele, există câteva clase de probleme
și potențiale cazuri de utilizare unde ne așteptăm
ca calculul cuantic să aibă un impact.
Acestea includ simularea, cum ar fi
modelarea proceselor și sistemelor care au loc în
natură, căutarea și optimizarea,
care presupune găsirea celei mai bune sau
optime soluții într-o situație cu
multe răspunsuri posibile, și matematica
și procesarea datelor cu structură complexă,
inclusiv aplicații pentru machine learning.
Algoritmii cuantici adoptă o nouă abordare față de
aceste tipuri de probleme, valorificând
caracteristicile unice ale fizicii cuantice, cum ar fi
superpoziția, interferența și entanglement-ul.
Calculatoarele obișnuite se blochează
explorând anumite zone ale spațiului computațional,
astfel că nu pot găsi aceste tipare.
Calculatoarele cuantice sunt dotate cu
capabilități suplimentare sau performanță crescută
pentru anumite probleme, oferite de natura lor cuantică.
Pentru a înțelege pe deplin potențialul calculatoarelor cuantice
e nevoie de o aprofundare a teoriei complexității computaționale,
o ramură a informaticii care se concentrează pe
măsurarea și compararea efortului computațional necesar
pentru a rezolva diferite tipuri de probleme.
Aceasta oferă un cadru util
pentru descrierea diverselor accelerări
și a claselor de probleme întâlnite în
calcul.